all right uh we'll be working from m i
want you to understand the strategy
okay I have weapons on so I'm trying to
isolate arms so I can create angles of
attack so I can't draw my weapons cuz he
can start defending it but if I if I can
isolate an arm then I have this whole
angle of attack that I C I created a
zone of sanctuary for my weapon okay so
we want to look for these arm
isolations I want you to think
differently uh when someone is trying to
get you off of them with various arm
pushes okay so for example he pushes up
on the chest I want you to understand
that he moved his elbow away from his
torso and that is the beginning of
isolating that arm it's the same in your
Tachi waza you're you're keihan is
building built that in already the elbow
is away from the Torso that's what
isolates the arm hence all your pins and
stuff off of the arm okay or he pushes
my
knee same thing the elbow has moved away
from the Torso and that is the exposure
I want to begin isolating that arm okay
as opposed to in my mind he's pushing my
knee and I pop it off and I go back down
okay when to change our
mind um so let's say he's uh some of
some of your bigger guys are trying the
hip pushes where you push the guy off at
the hips so hey you're trying these
things all right but again if you look
when he goes to push his arm is isolated
do you see his elbows away from his
torso all right so to first introduce
the concept of what we're going to do is
one usually a guy reveals what he wants
and where you feel the pressure okay
sometimes if you're skilled enough you
read it right away but other times you
might have to wait until he tries
something and then you set him up to try
it again so let's say he's pushing on my
knee okay and I know I pop it and then I
let him do that again and now I'm
looking for it okay and then I've
isolated the arm got it yes sir okay or
you can feel what he's doing go we can
feel it and then you'll get it
okay so we know when we're doing we know
why we're doing now how do I do it so
you're going to Yin yield what he's
moving so you Yin yield
that and then that's going to make the
arm uh the elbow light so as you come
around you healed enough okay if you're
strong enough just pop it all the way
around if you're not strong enough you
can use the leverage generated by using
the fulcrum the mat as a fulcrum okay so
he's trying to tighten it back in and
bring it back in and I'll just keep
using the leverage of the mat to get it
over and we'll isolate it here here in
arm cross face and again I created that
angle of attack where I can draw my
weapons okay so that's the first one go
slow he goes I yield the knee just
enough underneath if I'm strong enough
I'll just pop it all the way around if
I'm not I start to use the mat to lever
it around then I isolate it and I have
this Zone here okay let's try that arm
isolation yes sir we
go so again you'll look for that and
your best angle of attack to generate is
to get an angle canellation on his arm
and remember that's going to be across
his body so just like standing it's
diagonally across his body this time is
this way across his body
okay uh if he's pushing on your hips
again he's pushing on your hips right
before you start to go you feel it go
ahead you'll slightly turn you see how I
slightly turn yes sir okay and then you
have the same exact movement again if
you need the leverage use the mat if you
come on this
side and I won't do it
hard
okay so go
slow as he push and I turn I'll Attack
that wrist lock there you see yes sir
and even if I don't get it it'll draw
his mind there and it'll make that
easier to do so make sure that you you
feel that and you're attacking that so
he goes to push I yield on that hip and
I attack this arm and I'm up and over
and I have my attack all right if for
some weird reason you don't have your
knives on you or your handgun you still
have an angle attack here okay
especially on a thin guy like this
with thin clothes you actually have to
calculate that okay so you can do your
looping back knuckle fist right here
into those floating ribs okay uh you can
tap okay uh give them a couple to make
sure you're hitting it and you hit with
your whole body so you're not just here
bending at the elbow your whole body
goes boom in okay when you hit you see
how I generate that force in in my body
the same shoulder yield you use in all
your IO techniques it's just really
small and tight boom and I hit with it
okay all right we'll try it for the hip
yes sir uh go slow so you don't tweak
someone's wrist on the other arm
go all right uh we'll do another knee
push one so I'm going to yield push it
down and come back over and you created
that same zone of sanctuary here
okay so you can draw your weapons if you
don't have them of course is pinned down
and you're doing your elbows here
there's nothing nothing over here is
going to guard that okay so he he might
try to get that thing in there right but
go back I'm when I throw my strike I'm
aware of that so he's going to go he'll
feel that punch and you'll see how I
keep shielding that other arm from my
angle of attack you see that yes sir
okay and then boom I'll drop that elbow
in okay and it'll do it again just
reverse it when you come back okay so
you hit boom back and boom and you'll
hit again and I got my other trap on the
other arm now okay so we'll do it
again he goes to push yield step over
come
over tap trap that other arm from
blocking you same thing your body this
is just Cy hole with your bow boom
reverse it and you come back and hit
again
okay let's try
it feel the
pressure all right in all of these don't
give up any more of the mount than than
you have to okay so as he goes to push
the knee for example I don't want to go
like
this
he goes to push the knee everything is
heavy right
Tristan okay so um sing the ABCs push
the
kneeing ab c d e f g okay sing the ABCs
AB
C okay do you understand yes sir
okay let's do the a chest push one so
the same thing he goes to push P you
know you can swim through right okay I'm
going to do one very similar to The Hip
so as he this to push I'm going to turn
my body you see and smash one arm
down then I've done
it again he goes to
push that's too much off of
him he goes to push just turn your body
land on it it's not full is it right no
okay but sing the ABCs AB b c d e f g h
i j k it's full enough okay and we'll do
the gift wrap
here um so now this is to you right pair
pair isolations okay so once you isolate
one
arm and you start hitting him
he's going to have to defend so he's
going to put the arm up do you see and
it's away from his elbow again and then
you can isolate it again and now you
have your angle attack boom drop
whatever okay so we'll do both arms here
one arm at a time comes up turn put your
weight on it find the gift
wrap there he did it he's doing that one
go ahead to do whatever you want so
again you use the mat isolate it and I
start working it the other way now I
have both okay do something else with
your arm let's say he starts pushing on
me or blocking you see he's blocking you
go around it and you have it again okay
so let's do the blocking one blocking
yield you see I yield I go around it
boom shove it down and I'm in and now
you have both isolated
okay let's try it yes sir okay so when
he does the chest
push his elbows are away from his torso
but he's also got space underneath his
armpits which allows for a higher amount
okay so we'll go back down again he goes
I feel him doing that and I'll just come
up okay and then you have again you're
trapping his arms you have your weapons
here you can chill boom boom boom okay
you have your wrist locks you can do it
you don't s time okay so it's all about
timing he goes this is going to be too
late as I feel him
going and I come up boom boom boom draw
draw wrist walk whatever you want okay
here we go hey the mat is
deceiving okay so for example
we had this one check right sir okay and
uh I'll I'll do this but uh Say tap tap
tap when you when you don't like it
okay okay go back here we go
again ch ch ch okay uh and I'll do it
lightly but you'll be able to hear it so
come
back it's on his I'm scraping his
head c c you see yes sir on the ground
okay and that does not feel good and
then when you hitch here I'll just apply
pressure again that part doesn't hurt
but watch the other side of your head
okay do you see that um so these look
like little tiny things but they're not
so when you come back around listen
again you hear it again on his head okay
you come back around boom I came off and
then you're going to do the same thing
it's the ground that's hitting him so
again it does hurt on his face but I'm
actually using the
ground okay to get that same thing
little tiny things let's say he pushed
on my chest okay you came up this way
this looks like nothing but and you
drive all your weight in there it's
actually quite devastating okay guys got
it the mat is very
deceiving all right
that's it